no matter how much ricardo ruby turns
the tap nothing comes out he'd like to
wash his hands after a long day at work
often we've had water in the mornings
before work
but then none in the afternoon
nothing comes out of the tap
and then we have to wait until six seven
eight or even nine at night before we
get any
so the dishes will have to wait too
it's the same for this entire
neighborhood one reason is increasing
urbanization
there aren't enough pipelines and a
modern water treatment plant is still
under construction
over half of costa rica's population
lives here in the greater metropolitan
area surrounding san jose
increasingly it's encroaching on nature
[Music]
this river originates high up in the
central volcanic mountain range in the
middle of the forest
but it immediately runs through farmland
and meadows used to raise livestock
then right after that comes the edge of
the city which is steadily creeping
outwards
and straight after that it gets
swallowed up by the dense urban area
manuel guerrero's water fund aguatika
works to protect water sources by
bringing together farmers public
institutions and civil society
you can't drink the water from this
river it's completely contaminated
in many places toxic chemicals are
dumped into it
waste from agriculture the breeding of
livestock waste from urban areas or
industry is all discharged into the
river
there's no system in place yet to treat
the water properly and there's no system
to collect and reclaim the water
treating the water is one thing
but manuel guerrero and his partners are
mainly concerned with how water is used
and protecting the supply so they work
with farmers and support their efforts
to develop sustainable farming methods
that includes protecting woodlands
three decades ago large swathes of
forest were still being cleared to make
way for grazing land
today the farmers know that forests are
key to protecting water sources
[Applause]
[Music]
my grandfather was the first to farm
this land
we've been producing milk here for
around 40 years
my father hedged the creamery
for the last two years i've been working
here and learning all about dairy
farming
the farm's 200 cows are always put out
to pasture in different places to give
the grass time to recover this also
helps to spread their dung and urine
more evenly reducing water contamination
finca robles is a model for sustainable
farming in the region especially as the
effects of climate change become more
obvious
we're definitely affected by climate
change
it rains less now
we used to get more rain especially
during the rainy season
and the dry season is now drier still
over the years the climate has changed
and when the grass doesn't grow we have
to buy feed and that increases our costs
[Music]
carla braley and her family have
committed to keeping one third of their
farm covered with woodland
[Music]
in return one of aguatica's partner
organizations pays them compensation
equaling roughly five percent of their
income
the forest is so vital because that's
where the water reserves we rely on are
found
there are many water resources in these
woods
the trees preserve this water by
absorbing it
so for us this resource is hugely
important
it's super important
we've managed to combine pastures and
woodlands on our terrain
and the trees provide shade in some
places and conserve water in others
farmers who transform part of their land
into a forest ecosystem can play a key
role in protecting costa rica's water
supply says manuel guerrero
the farmers realize that they stand to
benefit from adopting these
environmentally friendly practices and
moving away from traditional style
intensive farming which produces many
harmful substances
and this then reduces the sources of
pollutants entering the water
but there's still a long way to go
before that water is sure to reach the
cities
at six o'clock in the evening ricardo
rubi still hasn't seen a drop
no yeah
but he at least stored a little water in
advance both for himself and his two
dogs he collects water for them in
plastic jugs because here every drop
counts
you